hello freak [ __ ] about the
evolutionary toolkit is that I believe
we have exactly the tools for navigating
this puzzle they're built into us also
in addition to this latent program but
we are now in a very dangerous situation
because for example if Google and other
of these online goliaths start deploying
algorithms that decide what we get to
talk about and see then we cannot use
the very tools that are necessary in
order to escape and avoid something like
civil war which frankly communication
and debate analyzing all the components
of this issue completely objectively
yeah I'm taking the risks that are
necessary with that and some of the
risks are that if we have free and open
communication that some percentage of
that communication is going to be
reprehensible and deplorable but yes but
that but that the consequences of
suppressing that are so much more
dangerous than the consequences of
allowing it that they're not in the same
universe yes we empower those terrible
ideas by making them I mean
electronically taboo yeah and then point
is there going to fester whereas if we
just if we discussed them we can defuse
the ones that are terrible we can spot
the opportunities that we don't know we
have and we can we can move forward
rather than descend into civil war which
frankly looks more like this issue with
with Google and YouTube let's say and
these other gigantic internet companies
you know it isn't a matter of if they're
going to produce automated BOTS that do
pre perceptual censorship they are doing
that let's explain what outside
explaining about well he tweeted the
other day that and I knew this was in
the workings because I've been looking
at what YouTube and Google are planning
with regards to their artificial
intelligence censors let's say you know
they want to get to the point where the
the the appalling video is not even put
up so what happened I hope I've got this
exactly right but God was in the process
you upload a video and then you publish
it and so once you upload it
YouTube has access to it and they have
access to its content and they informed
him that it would be d monetized before
he published it is right here we put up
on
bored there you go YouTube thinks that
my pointing to astounding hypocrisy is
too triggering there is nothing
objectionable object objectionable in my
clip unbelievable yeah and that one was
a manual review so I'm wrong about that
although how in the world they decided
that they were going to manually review
God's video is also I mean how many
videos are going up on YouTube what the
hell why are they manually reviewing his
and I mean God's at is not a radical
right no that's the thing I mean he's an
evolutionary biologist and that makes
him a radical now it does because he's a
bunch of questioning what's happening
and by questioning what's happening you
instantaneously get lumped into this
right-wing hate yeah well he's also
making the claim that human beings have
an intrinsic nature and so now there's a
new buzz phrase that goes along with
that and so that's that you're a
biological essentialist and you see so
if you're a radical postmodern
neo-marxist your theory is human beings
can be anything that I want to make them
into it's a core doctrine of the theory
and it's part of what makes it intensely
totalitarian because then human beings
are just putty for the molding and
that's part of the the motivational
Drive for claiming the radical
constructionist claim there's no
biological essence well why do you make
that claim well because we want to free
people from prejudice and tyranny it's
like no that's not why you make that
claim you make that claim because well
you want to justify your claim that
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
making over humanity in the in an image
of your ideology and and and that's that
would that that was a well documented
intellectual argument that that wove
through what happened in communist
Russia for example because the claim
they're explicitly was you wipe out the
past there's no real biological identity
you can mold the human of the future in
the image of your perfectionistic
ideology and and the Russians actually
sidelined themselves effectively with
respect to evolutionary theory that
basically they were so backward on a
biological front that as they were
deploying this this very broken
ideological toolkit they were wrecking
their ability to think about about how
biology works and so what you're
pointing to about evolutionary
biologists it's not just that
question the content of evolutionary
biology is absolutely the opposite of
politically correct yes exactly because
nobody tells the biota what's right and
what's wrong the biota does what it does
and those of us who look at it and
attempt to understand what those
patterns are can't help but be deeply
politically incorrect almost all the
time and so the idea that the truth of
biology is actually going to become
unexpressible and we're going to move
ahead we're just gonna we're gonna we're
gonna sideline it so that we can move
ahead with this ideological stuff I mean
that is ecology is racist and sexist you
you well if I might biology and we're
gonna have to go back here in order to
collect a tool but biology does create
entities that have the potential for
racism in them in our genomes we carry
the potential for racism for Darwinian
reasons sexism is a little different
right it is so I'm about to become very
politically incorrect oh yeah I know oh
it is not possible for male genes to
gang up on female teams because all of
our genes spend half their time in male
bodies and half their time in female
bodies which does not mean that
civilization is fair with respect to sex
and gender but it does mean that there's
no biological basis for the evolution of
a patriarchal force that subordinates
women because whatever the patriarchy
does those who are part of the
patriarchy become female in the next
iteration and they suffer the
consequences of it this is not the case
with race unfortunately this is not a
good thing but it is a true thing in a
Darwinian sense one population can gang
up on another population and it has
happened again and again it explains all
of the worst chapters in human history
and so in some sense what I'm getting at
is that you want to understand that
process and once you understand what
your genes are actually
up to and you understand that your genes
their objectives in the universe are not
defensible what your genes want cannot
be defended in in rational terms then we
become free to do something else to
recognize that our genes are up to
things that we don't have any reason to
honor and we can we can basically take
them out of the control position but if
we imagine that what our genes are up to
must be all right and therefore it can't
include anything like racism then we're
just stuck then we don't have the tools
to to diffuse racism
you